One situation where
covariances show up
is when we try to
calculate the variance
of a sum of random variables.
So let us look at the
variance of the sum
of two random
variables, X1 and X2.
If the two random
variables are independent,
then we know that the
variance of the sum
is the sum of the variances.
Let us now look at what
happens in the case where
we may have dependence.
By definition, the variance
is the expected value
of the difference of the
random variable we're
interested in from its
expected value, squared.
And now we rearrange
terms here and write
what is inside the
expectation as follows.
We put together X1 with the term
minus the expected value of X1
and then X2 together with
negative the expected value
of X2.
So now we have the square
of the sum of two terms.
We expand the
quadratic to obtain
expected value of the
square of the first term
plus the square of the second
term plus 2 times a cross term.
And what do we have here?
The expected value
of the first term
is just the variance of X1.
The expected value
of this second term
is just the variance of X2.
And finally, the cross term,
the expected value of it,
we recognize that it is the
same as the covariance of X1
with X2.
And we also have this
factor of 2 up here.
So this is the general
form for the variance
of the sum of two
random variables.
In the case of independence,
the covariance is 0,
and we just have the sum
of the two variances.
But when the random
variables are dependent,
it is possible that the
covariance will be non-zero,
and we have one additional term.
Let us now not generalize
this calculation.
Here is for reference
and comparison
the formula for the case where
we add two random variables.
But now let us look
at the variance
of the sum of many of them.
To keep the calculation
simple, we're
going to assume that
the means are zero.
But the final
conclusion will also
be valid for the case
of non-zero means.
Since we have
assumed zero means,
the variance is the same
as the expected value
of the square of the
random variable involved,
which is this one.
And now we expand this quadratic
to obtain the expected value
of: we will have
a bunch of terms
of this, where i
ranges from 1 up to n.
And then we will have a bunch of
cross terms of the form Xi, Xj.
And we obtain one cross
term for each choice of i
from 1 to n and for each
choice of j from 1 to n,
as long as i is
different from j.
So overall here, this sum will
have n squared minus n terms.
Now, we use linearity
to move the expectation
inside the summation.
And so from here,
we obtain the sum
of the expected value
of Xi squared, which
is the same as the
variance of Xi,
since we assumed zero means.
And similarly here, we're going
to get this double sum over i's
that are different from j of
the expected value of Xi, Xj.
And in the case of
0 means again, this
is the same as the
covariance of Xi with Xj.
And so we have obtained
this general formula
that gives us the variance
of a sum of random variables.
If the random variables
have 0 covariances,
then the variance of the sum
is the sum of the variances.
And this happens in particular
when the random variables
are independent.
For the general case, where
we may have dependencies
and non-zero variances,
then the variance of the sum
involves also all the
possible covariances
between the different
random variables.
And let me finally add
that this formula is also
valid for the general
case where we do not
assume that the means are zero.
And the derivation
is very similar,
except that there's
a few more symbols
that are floating around.